yo what is up everybody this is prestige
for mad luigi and i'm going to be
showing you guys how to play gwent in
the witcher 3 because i think a lot of
people
might have him skip the tutorial because
they know the basic mechanics of the
witcher or they didn't really see it was
clearly so i'm just gonna be running
through a game of gwent which is uh if
you don't know it's a card game in the
witcher 3 that you can play at a variety
of locations i'm gonna basically just be
running through a game and explaining
what i'm doing and what it all is so i'm
going to go talk to this trader who can
sell me a bunch of stuff
as his main purpose but is another
purpose that this specific trader has is
that he might want to play gwen so there
are a lot of people that can you can
play went with whether it be from main
quest givers or
gwen masters or guys taverns and so you
can just go wherever you want so now you
can see you can also bet so i'm going to
bed i'm going to bet 10 coins that i win
trying to make some money
so this is a new game in the witcher 3
so that's why a lot of people i think
even that played the previous games
won't understand
what it is however it is really basic so
maybe this video might not go out to
anyone but regardless we're gonna go
through this so i'm gonna be running
through the basics in this video
and
so i'm not going to be it's not going to
be a full in depth of everything so i'm
just going to go with what i have right
here
and i'm just going to get right into the
game
not enough cards um let's check i don't
know enough cards
total cards and deck total number of
unit cards especially cards i don't have
enough cards
there we go we have enough cards all
right let's try the game
so you need i think i think it showed at
least
20 something cards
and
because you get those cards that your
full deck is in the beginning it's that
and then you choose it takes 10 out of
those randomly so you don't want to make
your deck too big because then you won't
be able to choose the cards that you
really want and at the beginning of each
game you can you can
are given the option to redraw two of
your cards so i'm going to go over to
those uh
weaker guys and i'm going to redraw him
and i'm going to redraw
um
i'm going to redraw this guy
so now you see i have these 10 cards and
these are these are it for the entire
game except if you have a special power
like uh for my faction or the northern
realms i get to draw one more card
so i have this to work with for three
rounds plus one extra my opponent who is
also northern realms will have the same
type of deal now the point of this game
is to put cards on the table
and to end the round with the more total
points and if you end the round with
more total points then you win all the
cards get discarded from that round and
you're left with the next round with
whatever you have left so you don't want
to use all your cards in one round since
then you lose the next two rounds it is
a three round game two or three wins
and they're also uh as there are
factions there are various leader
leaders and they give different leader
powers so we're gonna go right into it
um
so he plays that i'm actually gonna look
at this guy
so he has a special ability since you
can see this is there how much just
attack damage and points they're worth
and there are three types of uh
units there are short range mid range
and long range the long range is your
seed short range is your
mid count is your
short sword combat and then mid range is
like archery and stuff so place next to
a card with the same name to double the
strength of both cards oh that's why i
had two of them
oh
okay
well
well
and you can really only put down one
card per
turn so then your
uh teammate your opponent not teammate
what is it that gets to go
so i guess i'm just gonna
don't want to go out big let's
let's start start
small see i place one card now he goes
so he's gonna hey i have a card do we
just have the same
sim decks i have a really basic deck so
i'm gonna
let's see what i have and there are also
weather cards that can
uh
weaken
a certain type of unit there are three
different uh four to four different
weather cards i believe one to
weaken each section of unit so
says the strength of all range to one
and i just have two of those
so i'm going to play what he played
so right now i'm beating him because i
have two and he is one
oh whoa whoa
what
wait what
what just happened
place on your opponent's battlefield
and draw two cards oh so i just gave him
two cards i've never seen that card
before all right all right so he just
got two extra cards so he still has nine
cards and i have eight cards but i do
have a good advantage over it
um hmm what's what's this ability
choose one card from your discard pile
and play it instantly i don't have any
discard so her you want to use second
round
um
should i play another short
i'm gonna diversify a little bit
i really hope
oh i really can't
hmm
he doesn't have any range i don't really
want to play visit i'm not going to play
any range i'm just going to play this
guy
and see what he wants to do
what what
another one of those
really
he got another two cards he has so many
cards
okay so we gotta think about this since
he has a good advantage over us
so let's see i don't think
he can play a seven drop in one round so
you know i'm gonna say so and you can
pass your turn whenever you think you
want to give up or you think the other
enemy can't beat you so i'm gonna
i'm gonna pass
and i'm gonna hope that his one card
isn't enough to be he has an eight all
right well gg then
gg i know there were even eight in this
are you kidding me
are you kidding me right now
whatever
he had p pass
oh he might he might just be letting me
win this round
um
well i guess i have to play one guy
right
let's see if he if he's just gonna pass
again
oh so he passed so that means i play one
card i win
so yeah they just give you the victory
so now you see i have seven cards he has
ten cards he's basically just gonna be
play as many cards as you can
try and get the biggest
let's see wait come on get something
good get something good oh wait oh i can
choose
i i can choose which one i want
awesome all right all right all right
let's see i have a five
um i'm going to i could play him for
more cards
if i have two fives
i think i'm gonna choose a five
yeah i think i'll just choose a five
so that's ten oh oh okay okay okay
six a six ballistic dang
i think i'll place
my own
trebuchet
all right all right
so this is kind of just going to be a
mad dash playing cards however he has
i think he's going to win this because
he has more cards than me
and yes this is basically the game
he would he would need to pull six out
next turn
to win
i'd say it's kind of like my best bet
well what is this guy's ability place
oh
i don't have another one of those so
gg
um
um let's see let's see
that i'm actually i'm gonna i'm gonna
try something i'm gonna place that i'm
gonna hope he doesn't play a fog card
all right all right so now my gap is
seven
he does definitely have the opportunity
to
pull out a seven
but since he already played an eight i
think it's gonna be pretty surprising if
he can also play a seven so i'm just
gonna since if i keep playing i'm just
gonna lose
so i'm going to pass on my turn and hope
he can't beat me please don't beat me
please don't beat me
yes
all right boys
oh no he can all right jk that was i had
a i had a false
all right i thought you could only play
one card even if you're your opponent
passes you can play as many cards as you
want okay so and yeah i just i just lost
i just lost my money
all right
well that is the those are the basics of
the game gwent and you can go around the
world and beat better players and look
in
um
higher up shops to get better cards and
once you get all those better cards then
you can
build a better deck
and so those are basically everything i
want to show you guys for gwent i hope
you guys have enjoyed i am going to be
posting a lot more witcher content in
the coming days and i guess weeks so
keep looking around my channel if you
like witcher like the witcher 3 and you
thought this video was pretty swag so
that's about it i'm gonna see you guys
later peace out